this week President Trump could become
the first US president to recognize
Jerusalem as a capital of Israel his
decision is expected on Wednesday the
president is also considering moving the
u.s. embassy there from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem in a rare public appearance
Jared Kushner who leads the president's
Middle East peace efforts said his
father-in-law has not made up his mind
yet he's still looking at a lot of
different facts and that when he makes
this decision he'll be the one to want
to tell you not me I think that there's
a lot of instances of great trust
between Israelis and Palestinians I
think that there's not a lot of trust
between the leadership and I think
that's what we've been really working on
Seth Doane is in Jerusalem the city at
the heart of the israeli-palestinian
conflict Seth good morning good morning
from Jaffa Gate a market where both
Israelis and Palestinians mix here in
Jerusalem's Old City this is a city that
is claimed as the rightful capital by
both sides both Israelis and
Palestinians and for the most part other
countries have stayed out of the way
keeping their embassies in Tel Aviv and
allowing that the final status of the
city to be determined in peace talks
between Israelis and Palestinians but
that could be changing today is the
deadline for the Trump administration to
sign a waiver that it must sign every
six months to keep the US Embassy in Tel
Aviv and some Trump administration
officials have warned that options
including moving the u.s. embassy could
help the peace process gain momentum
hear the word from Washington is that
this week we could see a sort of half
step from President Trump with the
president making a statement that
recognizes Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel but does not yet move the embassy
Palestinian leaders warned that could
jeopardize the peace talks and also
warns of violence and across the region
diplomatic posts have been put on alert
and high security Nora really
interesting Seth Doane there in
Jerusalem thank you so much